поїхали поїхали
Стефані та мама моя Стефанія
Це загроза я враховують цю загрозу
безумовно рівень захисту мосту підвищує
так добре захищена так підвищується
рівень захисту а потім мостом їдуть вже
відразу
всі відпочиваючі які приїхали
потім уявити, що буде завдано
такий
машини з нього потрапляє це розряду
фантастики
ми розуміємо це може бути ракета це
можливо машина це може бути судно
які там проходить
землетрусу 9
можна зруйнувати
[музика]
вистачить курити де завгодно курите там де
ще не потрапив
Яке море
[музика]
Ну а для чого я тебе був Мені подобається
як люди метушні Оса пожежі приїжджають Але
люди в шоці очі вилазять У них
бігають метушаться намагаються руками згасити
а він уже всі душі говорити
[музика]
нього
[оплески]
[музика]
за Росію
Земля в ілюмінаторі Земля в
ілюмінатор Земля в ілюмінаторі видно
[музика]
[оплески]
ядерну бомбу ми кажемо загарку покурив
100 грам випив обійняв
партнера прийшла зайнялася сексом
[музика]
Я не розумію як можна жити в цій
країні не довіряти цій державі
найголовніше не довіряти і не вірити в
наших пацанів
хто як їде я більше ніж впевнена що
незграбний розумний Красені пачками
[сміх]
[музика]
Отже, ми зараз знаходимося
Білгородської області
нас у районі 500 осіб
зі зброєю, але при цьому ми не приписано
Абсолютно ніякої частини
тиждень ми прожили в скотських умовах
ніякого матеріального забезпечення
грошового забезпечення
[музика]
що там нічого
раптом хто не знав на війні взагалі
загалом люди ось як зробити максимально
небезпечного воїна, який [ __ ] не вміє
беремо простого селянина який
взагалі нічого не вміє і ми його навчаємо
працювати з списом Там два тижні Все
відправляємо на війну
будь-якого елітного бійця лицаря який
10-15 років тренувався просто селянин
довге
потрапив у око поки
нікому не потрібні підготовки рівним рахунком
0 ми живемо те, що самі собі купуємо ми
витратили охерене кількість бабок
щоб просто поїсти
а
[музика]
здоровий підете воювати з ким з
фашистами
а проти кого
[музика]
підтримайте мобілізацію у Росії
трошки ні А так звісно я всіма
руками за
це ж прийшла
чорний мішки на ваших
[музика]
зараз багатьох мучить Питання які
спальні мішки з собою взяти в Україну
120 160 або 240 л Давайте розбиратися
120 літрів
160 літрів
це не додалося
240 літрів
Висновки робіть самі
[музика]
повернулася
[оплески]
[музика]
існує думка що незабаром
спеціальна військова операція перейменують
контористична операція хтось каже
що це буде навіть Вітчизняна війна
Але я вважаю що цього недостатньо
правильно це назвати Священна війна
[оплески]
[музика]
Калінінградську область Росії яка
знаходиться між Литвою та Польщею може
забрати собі Чехії вже повідомляється що
якщо там провести референдум, то 97
відсотків жителів виявили б бажання
приєднатися до Чехії зараз у Чехії
навіть створено спеціальний сайт який
присвячений крав вівцю в якій буде
перейменований Калінінград прямо на сайті
написано що кралівець тобто
Калінінград знаходиться в Чехії після
успішного референдуму 97 відсотків
мешканців Калінінграда вирішили
приєднатися до Чехії та перейменувати
Калінінград у краловиці жителі
Калінінградської області могли б
попросити Чехію ввести війська щоб
встановити там демократичну владу та
закінчити російську гегемонію вона
чеському сайті петицій з'явилася петиція
автори якої вимагають приєднання
російського екс-клава до Чехії як
підстави для приєднання наводиться
історичний факт, що місто кенігсберг
був заснований чеським королем прожимислом
атакарем другим петиції вже підписала
більше 13 тисяч осіб у ній зазначено
що Росія своїми діями в Україні
автоматично дозволила вести війська в
Калінінград і провести там референдум про
приєднання до Чехії
[музика]
він кричав, що тобі не треба географію
знати коли у твоєї країни ракет більше
населення України
[сміх]
Ну скажи чий
ти скажи
що
[музика]
нам знак
нам
знаєш, що зараз боюся
вже ну там американці там за них все ось
ці ось там ще
як би вони це ти американці не
здогадалися не зібрали б цих знову
всіх вояк-то Сталлоне Арнольда нахуй Це
тут коли не разом цього горішка
міцного там ще
зараз ось вони додумаються зібрати щось нам
точно
Я не знаю цей Майкл дугу стали Хто він
як у Росії тут знаю може хоч він за
нас піде хоч ще шанс якийсь буде
[музика]
набрали повітря і за моєю командою щодо
три рази два три
[оплески]
[музика]
челенджень
робіть хоча б татуювання з вашим
ім'ям та прізвищем щоб ми знали як
знайти ваших рідних коли вас вб'ють
тунець
[музика]
Ну, привіт мамо
українську тому що вже пустушку
задський намисто мій справий чудові були і
поле вина ми пори ми з тобою
[музика]
ночі вони катує людей він їх буває
дітей
[музика]
знімав Instagram їх завивав
суперкай просто скинь Донат
ти та ти
чекайте нашим
[музика]
Мама
відриває
[музика]
Суржик саак золотування російську мови
Так що він не соромтеся А балакай
куміти я так українською мовою ви не
дивуєтесь свиня у мене така фаріона
[оплески]
вона подавилася сюди я його синівлю
такий закони можна буде
[музика]
добровільності не закрили
я заявляти
[музика]